mark Edmondson why Reid why Reid will
the compressed answer is to change your
life to make it a little bit better than
it is when did you first start reading I
started reading I started being read to
actually by my father and the first
thing I can remember having read to me
was the Rime of the Ancient Mariner
which my father read over and over again
until I successfully memorized it and
then we were through you actually
memorize well it's not all that long and
he knew it by heart so we thought that I
can still do absolutely not how does
reading change your life
well the way I like to put it is this
that we all get socialized one time
around by parents and teachers and
schools and priests and ministers and
what-have-you and for a lot of people
those values will do just fine their
community values their long tested and
long tried and there's something
eminently respectable about them but
there are other people who for whatever
reason just don't fit right into the
established values they find themselves
disgruntled dissatisfied by even with
the best meaning teachers and parents
said those people go a lot of different
directions but one of the best
directions they can go is to become
obsessed readers they read and read and
read until they start to find people who
see the world in a way that's akin to
theirs and then they feel at their home
they got a second set of parents and
second set of teachers and they can
start seeing the world for themselves a
little bit different from where the
community sees it often how often do you
read something that you totally disagree
with oh all the time all the time give
us an example um I read Updike's most
recent novel right I guess what I
disagree with in there the optic is a
wonderful verbal artist spectacular
technique wonderful language but I
disagree with the kind of suburban
nihilism that under writes the thing
this sense that you know all the
characters are pawns they're all small
they're all tiny and they in the end
they're to be patronized and
condescended to rather than looked at
you know somewhat more optimistic and
Emersonian terms
what's an eel list an e list is somebody
who doesn't believe in anything right
where's the dead term come from
I assume it comes from the Latin word
Nico which means nothing right so to
believe in nothing um is a great
temptation in the modern world when
there are no assurances out there for
people nature's greatest fear was that
people who became disabused by religion
and by politics and by all the other
social norms out there would become
nihilism believe in nothing and the
result would be that they lead very
small lives in which they'd only think
about pleasure and they'd only think
about their own advantage you tell a
story in your book about the time you
spent in in Vermont at Woodstock yes
what when was it and what's the story
from the headmaster this was in 1977 and
we were at a place called the Woodstock
country school in Woodstock Vermont and
I maintained that it was the last hippie
school in America we had two rules rule
number one was don't hurt anybody and
rule number two was we didn't really
know and the headmaster the school was a
guy named Robin lever Robin lever was
tall with movie star good looks great
flashing smile blue eyes and his career
had been entirely in business if Robin
ever read a book all the way to the end
I don't know what it was but he was a
terrific educated nonetheless because he
strongly believed that every kid who
walked into that school had something
that he could do that could make him
happy and could also make a contribution
to society and we had some pretty hard
cases their parents the parents would
walk in sometimes and say my kids loser
good luck with him right actually a
parent would say that about a kid
absolutely there we were the court of
last resort and Robin really liked
sixteen and seventeen year old kids and
he just would keep his peace and take
the kid in and by virtue of you know
really observing them carefully and
seeing what it was they might have to
offer I think we accomplished some good
things you know Leever I don't think
ever read Emerson but there's a Lydon
Emerson that he would have loved the
power that is in you is new in nature
you know the power that was in each of
our individual kids was new in nature
and so he would sit there in meeting and
we go through each of the kids and he
had light on one who was failing
everything and it's a what's he
interested in what does he like what
does he love everyone looking at
it's nothing out there that Michael long
really likes to do some he said well I
saw him following the farmer around
maybe likes that marm said okay no more
English no more history put him to work
in the farm he liked it and he began to
develop a little bit next term is back
in English and history this is part of
leave his faith that there's a little
germ of something special in everybody
and what a teacher is supposed to do is
look hard and find it and then give it
some encouragement and you caught up
with the headmaster 25 years later I did
I did we had an interesting exchange we
were talking about why the school failed
and I said we just had to take too many
borderline kids right some of these
people were nearly dangerous and he said
no no mark they just needed more time we
just didn't have enough time for them
some of them needed four and five and
seven years right that was very moving
to me and he was still out ahead of me
in a certain sense in thinking about
people's possibilities I tried to bring
that back into my own teaching and so
far as I could
how old were you and you were at
Woodstock I was a young teacher I was 24
to 27 years old what years that was from
1977 to about 1980 what education did
you have before you got there I had a BA
from Bennington College and whatever
degree they should have given at the cab
driving garage that I drove out of in
New York City did you do a graduate
degree somewhere eventually I did after
I did in my three years at Woodstock I
went to Yale University and did a PhD
there in English and then what and then
having had you know there's a great line
in Salle Bellas Adventures of Augie
March 3 says various jobs the rosetta
stone in my life up until that time I
had about 40 jobs and since that time
I've had one in the Fester of English at
the University of Virginia so every
semester you teach how many kids what
course it varies a great deal but the
heart and soul of my teaching is the
Romantic poets English in America
I teach Emerson and Whitman Emily
Dickinson on the other side of the
ledger I teach Blake could Wordsworth
and Keats and Shelley and for a little
bit of opposition I teach Jane Austen in
your book you write about Marcel Proust
yeah I must confess I wouldn't know much
about Marcel Proust if it hadn't have
been for this show and a visit we made
number of years ago not too long ago two
Shelby foots home in Memphis Tennessee I
want to show you just a little clip from
this program we did with them and ask
you why people read Marcel person okay
my mother gave me this full volume boost
for my 17th birthday and every time I
feel I've earned the right to do it I
quit everything and reread Proust
I've done it in the back of this when I
wrote each time that as the 9th reading
in 1993 I haven't felt justified and
taken off two months since 93 so you've
written you've read this book these
Nana's foot 3,000 pages yep mm-hmm
nine times right this white reading it's
a two reasons one is pure pure enjoyment
Proust is one of the most entrancing
writers that ever lived
and the second he can teach you
something you can always learn a writer
can learn from Proust and he can indeed
we we talk about Shakespeare that's the
grand master teacher when we stand over
here so folks I see you better what is
it about the written word that's either
attractive to people or it separates
from television I really think that the
written word is what defines us as
superior creatures to all the other
creatures on earth man is characterized
by a number of things one of them is
he's here only animal that knows he's
going to die someday
and knowing that he also has an
obligation to make the most of whatever
time he has and making the most of his
enormous Lee assisted by reading by
learning about the world mark Edmondson
that was in 2001 and shall we foots room
where he wrote to Civil War has been
part of it mmm-hmm what about Marcel
Proust not if he's read it nine times
hmm why would you do that well Proust is
maybe the greatest stylist in the 20th
century nobody can write as long a
sentence that says gorgeous and
as revealing right his language is
beautiful his metaphors are spectacular
but as Foote says he knows a whole lot
about life I don't know that there's
anybody would the possible exception of
Freud who is thought as hard and as
unsentimental II about love as Proust
has he's just unremitting in his
analysis of it especially in the middle
three volumes I think that maybe what
shall be for its getting out when he
talks about all the things that Proust
has to teach have you ever read that
remembrance of things past I have how
many times I don't go through it in the
consecutive way that Shelby Foote does
I'll read a couple of volumes than a
couple more but I guess you'd have to
say that I probably read it twice but
never never in a run-through you also
say that you read it to learn about what
you really are what you are a and in
instead of what proof says what do you
think of yourself
ya boost is that wonderful line where he
talks about how readers will come to
understand themselves by seeing the
world through his eyes and some of what
he has to say will resonate with them
and that'll be marvelous but some of it
won't and then he says but you shouldn't
criticize me if it doesn't that's just
the part of the book that's not about
you it's just about me who else would
you read if you had time you have free
time you can read anybody tell us who
that would be
well to me the two greatest authors in
English are Ralph Waldo Emerson and
William Shakespeare and if I had to name
one that I prefer for the education of
young people if I had to ask my kids to
read all of one rather than all the
other it would undoubtedly be Ralph
Waldo Emerson let me show you a little
bit of Robert Richardson and right here
some time ago back in 1995 he wrote a
book fire on ice about hmm Emerson let's
see just a little bit of what he had to
say there were some and Thoreau were the
people that I read when I'm feeling bad
they they're people I come away from
reading them feeling better about myself
in the world and my friends in the
country and this this ability of Emerson
to reach the individual to reach me
alone not as part of a party or group or
anything else but just the individual I
think it's something he still has I find
that when one puts this in front of
young people
they respond and they take it up agree
he's right on the head there when he's
especially when he talks about the
individual Emerson speaks to the
individual and tells the individual to
treasure his own thoughts his own
perceptions and his own projects even
when the human cries against them he's
the great writer of the individual
pitted against society and anybody who's
feeling hemmed in by what they take to
be a sterile conformity he's going to go
to Emerson just as Richardson is
describing and find an ally there
immediately and that's that is his great
wealth it seems to me but the
interesting thing about Emerson is that
not only is he somebody who's a
wonderful prophet of self-reliance and
vision and poetry he's also very prudent
tough Yankee and he suggests that there
are times when you got to be a little
bit more vigilant than outrageous and I
like those two sides of Emerson the fact
that he says prudential as he is daring
what city were you born in I was born in
Malden Massachusetts so you're right
around where he used to live right but
you gotta keep in mind growing up in
Malden and Medford as I did we might as
well have been 5,000 miles away from
Concord Massachusetts these are tough
Irish and Italian working-class towns
and anybody who claimed any kind of
converse with Emerson was an alien
immediately so when we entered is
tambours I first started reading Emerson
actually when I entered graduate school
I knew there was some kind of renewed
excitement about this guy various
teachers in mind were talking him up and
I wanted to see what it was they had on
the ball I tried him in college but I
found that the RO was far superior I
still loved the RO but Emerson to me is
number one so what do you go to Thoreau
for Thoreau is a tough brutal critic of
one central tenant one central tendency
in American life and that is consumerism
right simplify simplify simplify
there's no writer who knows more about
the perils of consumerism he talks about
how people are out there working hard
laying up making themselves sick laying
up money for the day that they fall sick
you know there's nobody better than
Thoreau for showing you that what SMAP
most valuable in life time nature
reading writing and getting you to get
some kind of distance on what's most
draining in life money stuff conspicuous
consumption accumulation the whole bit
he's so articulate about it's beyond
belief it's his central subject and he's
great
so if you wanted to recommend somebody
has never read Emerson one book that
they might read to be fulfilled on
Emerson what would it be I would open up
the Rose Walden and if I were pressed
for time I would just read the chapter
called economy that's what about Emerson
in Emerson I would look at the great
essay self-reliance and then all of the
other essays in the first series so when
you how many kids are in your class when
your teacher
ranges from twenty to forty you say in
your book that you sometimes have a
rather raucous teaching style can you
explain that well I ask them questions
that sometimes raise the roof a little
bit like well we're reading 1984 and I
say hey if you woke up tomorrow morning
in 1984 big brother world had taken hold
how would you behave would you be like
Winston Smith challenging the system
would be like Julia who's a rebel from
the waist down and one woman raises her
hand and says I'd be like O'Brien he's
the guy who tortures Winston Smith he's
the worst person in the book why would
you because like everybody else in this
university I'm trying to succeed and get
ahead and I believe if I woke up in that
society I'd probably try to succeed and
get ahead - well this caused chaos
because some people didn't want to be
associated with O'Brien but it hit a
nerve with other people said yeah she's
more or less right you know I could see
myself being in complicity with the
party and Big Brother you say you have
an attitude about a student can say
anything they want to in your classroom
even if it's homophobic or racist or
anti-semitism edek the why because you
want a classroom to be a free speech
zone where all ideas can get examined
freely and with detachment and also with
on the part of the teacher a certain
amount of affection these are people who
are in the process of growing they're
not grown yet and there's a kind of it's
a transitional period that they're in
and in all to the good also I think a
lot of the kind of angry conservative
movement that rubs me the wrong way the
Rush Limbaugh kind of stuff came about
because people going to college felt all
my professors are liberal I could never
give them my reservations about the
liberal line so that those things Fester
didn't get darker and nastier and then
you know welcome to talk radio there
they are expanded to 90 times their size
if they'd be listened to in a tolerant
and disagreed with an affectionate way
we might have a little bit better civil
discourse in the country so you think
there's something to this liberal
professor thing sure sure
it goes two ways though professors are
liberal there's a lot of flexibility of
mind that I see among my college whom I
admire a great deal students are often
hypersensitive feeling that you know if
I disagree with the professor it might
harm my grade well that's a craven
reason not to want to disagree with the
professor um
the professor might hate me and you know
fail me that's a reasonable reason but I
don't think that's the case all that
much still one of the things that
English departments in particular need
to do is to become receptive to hiring
more people who have conservative
political views you can't have a real
dialogue if all you have are liberals
leftist leftist to the left of leftists
well concert' i've heard the
conservative talk show host say that
students pandered to their professors
because if they don't they will flunk a
course do you think that's true in any
case I think it's rarely true when I sit
down in meetings you know I can only
speak from my own experience I sit down
in meetings with my colleagues they're
fair-minded judicious thoughtful people
and they are the same as graders and
they're the same when they talk to their
students and then the same when they
teach um I just think that our lifes
would be enlivened a lot if
conservatives didn't think that the
profession of English teaching at the
university level was for all purposes
close to them it shouldn't be nice a
mistake on our part in your book you
kind of teed off on Jerry Falwell who
teaches in your state and runs Liberty
University in Lynchburg not far away
from Charlottesville where your school
is why why did you pick him out um I
picked him out because to me he stands
for a tendency and American thought
that's moving to simplicity and anger
and fear and self-righteousness um
and what I'm hoping that literature is
going to do is take people toward
complexity and thoughtfulness and irony
and subtlety um at the same time I got
to say when I look out into the world
now and see how little sure faith there
is in religion and government even media
I understand why people panic and want
easy answers you know the process of
Education
be reaching out to people in the middle
of the country and other places who want
the easy answers and inviting them into
a way of talking and thinking a way of
reading that lets them see the world in
more complex ways that ultimately does
them good what do you think the liberal
college professors reaction would be if
they had to send all their kids to
schools that had teachers like Rush
Limbaugh when they were tax payer
supporters school uh-huh well maybe
inevitable reaction of liberals who
don't like where the kids are going to
school is to send them to private
schools immediately and I know sometimes
conservatives feel that they're being
taught by a liberal cabal it's not true
it's not true
it should be more varied than it is but
in terms of enforcing politically
correct norms there's a smidgen of it
but it's not the overwhelming or there's
an heir there's a tradition of Tolerance
at universities and it's lived with
qualifications quite well for a long
time ever since I've been there anyway
there's another subject you talk about a
lot poetry nikki giovanni teaches and at
Virginia Tech and in the same state you
do and she was here and this year
talking about poetry let's listen a
little bit of what she had to say about
it
poetry is an essence when we want to
compliment anything when we want to
there was a super bowl last week you
know Sunday and we want a compliment
Alyssa name Brady and New England right
he's poetry in motion right we drink a
wonderful music knee you know and lovely
red wine and it's poetry in a bottle
right are you you make a crown roast of
pork and you slice into it and it's it's
poetry right poetry what is it that's
beautifully put up and what she's
emphasizing is the aesthetic or pleasing
dimension of poetry wonderful thing from
my point of view this can be more to it
than that and that is that people can
read a poet like Walt Whitman and say
that's exactly what I thought democracy
should be it's a place where nobody's
ever down on anybody else it feels
really good to live like that
Whitman shows me how this is a dimension
to the work it's not just aesthetic
beautiful
on her part but is also ethical and
political in my book I try to bring that
side out you tell the story about Walt
Whitman and Ralph Waldo Emerson yeah
yeah it's just it's absolutely my
favorite story from American literature
um Walt Whitman is absolutely nobody
he's living in Brooklyn framing three
room houses he's done some newspaper
work he's written a bad temperance novel
or two um he keeps a journal he's an
eccentric no one has ever heard of him
outside of modern small circles in New
York nobody's ever going to hear of him
in all probability but then suddenly in
about 1854 you start to see
extraordinary things going on in his
journal he's reading Ralph Waldo
Emerson's work but he's also going to
the Opera and hanging out in Brooklyn
and hanging out in New York City and
looking around and at one point you see
a reading writing in the journal you
know if I were walking through heaven
and Yahweh himself came up to me there's
no way that I would tip my hat first
unless he tipped his to me so you can
see very strange and rich things are
percolating in Whitman's head he
finishes the book and he had some
published it's privately he brings it
around from one store to another tries
to sell it door-to-door it's mainly sell
sold out of phrenology shops these
joints where the the living assumption
is that by filling the bumps on
somebody's head you can tell exactly who
they are so it's in quack world and just
on a whim he sends it off to Ralph Waldo
Emerson who's got more prestigious than
all of our Nobel Prize winners put
together a Mersenne gets the book rather
than thrown in the trash bin he brings
inside and he reads it and he simply
blown away by it it's magnificent he
loves it and it's especially wonderful
because Emerson his entire life has
wanted to be a poet he thinks of his
essays as a warm-up for his poetry and
his poetry is really not very good he
writes a beautiful essay called the poet
which he describes exactly what an
American poet ought to be somebody is
expensive somebody who could take in the
lives of Western settlers and the
Indians and the hill people up in
Vermont and the traders and the
blacksmiths and everybody and ever since
poetry is only about him but here comes
the poetry that's about everybody he
writes back to Whitman right away and he
says
I'm so grateful for getting leaves of
grass it's the finest piece of wit and
wisdom that America has yet produced
it's terrific and then what does Whitman
do in the next edition of Leaves of
Grass he stamps it on the spine of the
book without Emerson specific permission
and sells more copies how mad did
Emerson get about that he was a little
bit annoyed but Emerson was a good sport
on some level and he was also simply
thrilled about this volume of poetry so
basically he let it go when you read
where do you read um I tend to read a
lying-down um usually I have a beaten up
old couch in my study and a lie in the
bed and read but sitting up isn't the
game for me I'm a lie-down reader and
how much in a day do you read it really
varies but you know I try to take home a
new book that I've never read every
weekend and go through that um all kinds
of different books novels histories
poems plays would have you and then
probably a couple of others during the
week and lots of magazines and
newspapers and stuff you got a couple of
kids I do how old are they uh my older
son is 15 and my younger son is 12 and
what do they think of reading um my
older boy was obsessed by reading and
being read to when he was very young
when he was about eight years old we
went through the totality of Don Quixote
right now he's mixed on the subject of
reading he'd rather play football or
ride a snowboard or travel or something
like that and my younger boy is not so
much a reader as a rock and roller he
writes his own songs and he practices
guitar and he blasts the roof off the
house with his drums had your dad not
introduced you to reading do you think
you would've been a reader I do um only
because I had that sense of kind of
being out of place of dislocation that a
lot of future obsessed readers get and I
would have quest it around until I
stumbled into something that um helped
me see the world in a way that you know
the people at the church weren't
necessarily seen it so I'm thinking so
yeah what did your parents do are they
still alive by the way my mother is
still alive she was a mom homemaker my
father was somebody who barely graduated
from high school and went on to be
through his own intense energy and
talent
an engineer at Raytheon Company and what
did he think about what happened to you
then at what year did he die my father
died in 1984 when he was in his mid-50s
so he didn't see a lot of what you're
done he didn't though he did come and
visit me one day at Yale and we took the
tour of the campus and we walked around
and as a very poignant moment because my
father was very proud and he would never
admit that he wanted anything that he
didn't have everything that we had was
great fine the best but we're walking
through the middle of the Yale campus
and he looked up at the buildings which
are sort of wonderful and in their
Gothic Xs sort of silly and he said
imagine spending your life in a place
like this rather than some plant like
Raytheon is very poignant moment because
truly he had the intellectual talent to
spend his life at a place like that and
it just never quite came to fruition for
him it was a different time Frank
McCourt Angela's Ashes was here and
here's a couple of comments from him I
stood in front of those classes for -
over 27 years talking exhorting evoking
and learning mostly I used to say to
them in Stuyvesant High School in
September in January when we get these
new classes and so by the end of this
term there's one person in this class
who will have learned the most that's me
as I want to learn and I would learn
something from each time for instance we
did Hamlet each year if you do it all
from God it just it keeps upon the play
keeps revealing itself what's it take to
want to learn and when do you see people
and clicking in on it well McCourt's got
his finger on it you really start to
learn when you become a teacher because
your gutter the next day they're going
to be asking you questions about it and
you got to be squared away it takes the
passion of teaching but it also takes a
conviction that I could make my life
something different from it is through
reading and then I think what's also in
the back of McCourt's mind is that I can
use this to make myself into a writer
and I know a friend of mine was in his
class as its divested and when Angela's
Ashes came out he said
love the book love McCourt but of course
he wrote the first draft over and over
again as he told these stories to us
time and time again so he was writing
then - do you write when you teach I
mean you think about that absolutely
yeah yeah so what are the kind of things
in this little book about why read that
you learn from your students I learned a
whole new way for instance of looking at
portrait of a lady you know
elgyn which was which was that tear
which is which is that henry james has
created this marvelous character Isabel
Archer who's beautiful free and young
and just arriving in Europe and being
courted by one rich old world potentate
after the next and she's full of high
spirits an American goodwill and
goodness um and reading the book before
I had always had a sense that she was
the most wonderful character in
literature but reading it with my
students and going slowly over it you
could see the James really disdained her
considerably and my students loved her
and I loved her but James quite
disdained her and what we saw together
not only that James disdained her and
her shallowness and small-time hubris
but would now call narcissism but the
James also somewhat disdained it in us
indirectly and we had to come to terms
with that dimension of us that was
aligned with Isabel Archer and a couple
of his students I say Isabel all the way
but a couple of the students said James
was right what was what's bad about it
is about Isabel all that optimism and
all that American high good cheer is bad
about me too
and I wouldn't mind having it purged
away by reading this book in the same
way that James purges it out of Isabel
by virtue of what happens to her as the
book unfolds ah what year do you start
teaching what you're in school are they
I teach every level from first year to
end in graduate students how often do
you get masala in further student a
blank slate someone who walks in and
it's the first time they're ever thought
about being serious about reading all
the students at the University of
Virginia are accomplished students you
know they've done well they've succeeded
this has gotten high scores we take in
250 valedictorian
but the big division is between people
who have a spirited drive to think and
talk about their lives and to analyze
themselves and to analyze the world
around them in political and social
terms and the ones that don't and
sometimes the kids who have the most
spirited drive to think and to analyze
things and to imagine things are not the
most intellectually talented but to me
that's the big division the people who
are spirited in their response and the
people who one would have to describe is
rather complacent how often do you learn
that a student has parents that aren't
the slightest bit interested in reading
and hadn't educated them before they got
there
well on continual of course finding
parents who say to this student to their
sons and daughters stay out of the
English department you must go to the
calm school you must be pre-med you must
be previous and you must be pre that
that's the major tendency we have
middle-class parents who value reading
but frequently the value will lose
success more to which I can only say to
the students it's ultimately your own
decision and often people need to know
themselves before they know what they're
going to do with their lives this is an
opportunity to know yourself you might
want to take is your as an elective or
people do people have to choose your
course by analyze their electives paul
johnson british historian wrote about
the history of the united states who's
here in 1998 said something i think
you'll be interested in look forward but
of course the book which mattered more
than any other in american history was
the bible you could say that america is
to some extent the product of the bible
because that was the book that the
original settlers carried with them they
read it conscientiously they went on
reading it their children and
grandchildren read it they often in
families it was the custom to go all the
way through the Old Testament in the New
Testament once a year and it was the
King James Bible as we call it was
something that was written into their
title-deeds and very much into the
language and it's often surprising
how frequently you come across
congressional auratus and presidential
origins which carry echoes of of the
Bible what you think true enough
true enough are some distinctions worth
making the Old Testament or the new you
know the New Testament to me is the
great book of Hope and the Old Testament
is the great book of power authority and
often alas revenge and I think America
has moved backward and forward between
the embrace of the New Covenant that the
New Testament represents Emerson's a
great champion of that and lapsing back
into the old rhetoric of sin and
damnation so it's not just that there's
been a book at the center of our culture
there's been a kind of squabble over
that book that's ongoing you ever talk
about the Bible in your class sure teach
it all the time how often do you find
students that know the Bible and then
some that don't have any idea about the
Bible well the students who know the
Bible best often tend to come from a
fundamentalist or a resolutely Christian
background but since they've showed up
for a literature course um they're open
to debating the whole thing and they can
be at the greatest pleasure conceivable
you say you're a long time agnostic
mm-hmm explain well I grew up Roman
Catholic um was part of the church until
I was 11 or 12 years old and then I came
to the conclusion to things that you
know as a young scientific empiricist
there was no proof for any of this stuff
and number two the level of prohibition
and thou shalt not was more than a
twelve-year-old self could stand so my
friends and I all rebelled
simultaneously the Luthor's of Multan
Massachusetts so church-going today at
all absolutely not
what about the family no not at all what
about the students um the students are
very mixed and you could never predict
based on sitting down and talking to
them how many will be resolute
churchgoers how many you know obligatory
churchgoers and how many complete
agnostics or atheists it's you don't
know how important is religion to this
country
it's a complex question religion is
absolutely central on one level 90% of
Americans believe that God knows and
loves them personally right and there's
a good deal of at least expressed
religious conviction but we make money
with such a grim fervor five days of the
week then walks out walk out to see our
pagan spectacle football the next day
and then go to church the next
it's a funny disparity there it's not
unresolvable but it's not easy to
resolve do you ever get into discussion
in the classroom and arguments about
this all the time how do you do it all
the time well you walk in there with a
book like Freud's future of an illusion
in which Freud is the crankiest and
least sympathetic atheist who ever lived
says simply what's religion religion is
the longing for the Father right we all
want to go back to the time when dad was
omnipotent and gave us complete
protection and complete love and so we
create religions that restore that early
state of things well this causes a
near-riot
sometimes what was your own relationship
with your dad um my father was a remote
difficult a highly intelligent person
and the things I gained got from him a
sense of Independence and determination
I greatly treasured the energy that he
had and conveyed to me I hope that I'm a
little bit less stubborn and unreachable
by argument than he is and maybe a
little softer do you change anything
about the way you relate to your own
boys because of your own experience sure
it's something of a generational thing
of course there's a shift in
child-rearing in general um no corporal
punishment a lot more talk than
punishment at all um attempt to be not
only an authority figure but an ally
couldn't quite say a friend that's not
exactly right to a child and also a
sense as quiet as it may be that comes
in many ways from the romantics that
there's a whole lot to learn from
children if you'll step back and watch
what have you learned recently from your
kids well my son Willy is the best
spontaneous blues improv improviser that
I know he's a wonderful artist on the
guitar and it's partly because he simply
lets it fly
and when I try to write different kinds
of new things new kinds of essays I just
did rack for a play um
it's his improvisational power that's
urging me on just a little bit where do
you write in your in your life in your
home or at your offices I have a
marvelous little building out behind my
house and it's got a word processor in a
couch and books falling all over the
place I have ideal circumstances how
long you had that by the way ever since
I moved to three years after I moved to
Virginia we moved out into the country
in Batesville so 17 years this book
why read looking is a hundred and
forty-six pages long it's relatively
small how long did it take you to write
this um well you know I love the answer
that our people black my gave when a
student showed up at his door and showed
my poem and black must show him three
poems in black my said I like this one
the best and the student said I wrote
that in five minutes and Blackmer said
how old he is son I'm 18 pakmar said
took you 18 years to write that took me
51 years to write that yeah you write
about David Denby in your book but you
write about him as a movie critic for
The New Yorker right we had him here
when he had written a book after he
spent a year going back to Columbia to
study great book oh great books here's
David when we look anyway Hegel also
sounded better aloud and I began to
understand him at last by reading it
declaiming against the late-night
traffic on West End Avenue that was a
lot of fun I was like climbing a
mountain in Phuket I'm falling back and
falling back and then climbing up and
falling back I it was it was difficult
but I felt every muscle straining I when
I finally got to the point I thought I
understand stood a good bit of the
introduction of the philosophy of
history I was very very happy that was
one of my high points I mean I know I
don't mean to make this sound like some
endurance test this whole year it was
great I was I was thrilled I was I felt
like I was pressing up against the frame
of my life every day what do you think
um it's moving it was a great premise
for a book I'm gonna go back to school
and I'm gonna do it right this time and
I'm going to integrate it into a richer
more complex adult life as to reading
hegel hegel is not my favorite
philosopher but I'm glad David laboured
through to understand you write a lot
about philosophers and your including
before I do you say you've spent your
life with yes why by the way Freud is
somebody who can tell you more about
yourself than anybody else when you're
feeling down and low and reduced right
for it is great on depression great on
mourning great on a love that's going
sour his view of human beings when
they're at their worst is astounding at
the same time it's somebody who
desperately needs a philosophy of
happiness to complement the philosophy
of grief that is pervasive in his work
but he's a great thinker is just a
stoical very tough-minded thinker far
too tough minded for a current addiction
to cheerfulness did you get a PhD at
Yale I did did you write about for it I
did I wrote a dissertation that talked
about Freud in the context of the
Romantic poets and I tried to offer a
romantic reading a poet's reading of
Freud tried to read him as a poet rather
than the 40 in readings that were so
fashionable at the time who is the
hardest philosopher that you study in
your life to understand Heidegger is the
hardest not because what he's saying per
se is so difficult but because the
experience that he wants to extend to
you is the experience of getting behind
Plato and what's broadly speaking the
rationalization of the world he wants
you to feel the mystery of being and so
it involves not only an intellectual
nimbleness but an emotional openness
that's very hard to come by Simon
Winchester wrote a book professor in the
madman about the Oxford English
Dictionary he talks about the English
language let's listen English is a
living language unlike the French who
said the Academy of Hall says you had
these the forty immortals who said this
is the French language and we're not
going to have words like the sandwich
and the weekend polluting our language
this is what it's fixed by us the
English said no English is not fixed
it's constantly changing constantly
evolving but the complexion the
complexity of that is that we have to
keep expanding our dictionaries so the
OED is now 20 volumes with 3 additional
volumes produced in the last five years
now sensibly it's going online on cd-rom
minutes but showing thanks to technology
it's living nature or the living nature
of the language are we lucky to be
living in an english-speaking country
versus a lot of the other languages you
might have studied well of course but
anybody will tell you that their
language is the best was wonderful I
mean English gives you yes he's exactly
right has that huge huge expanding power
it's just never going to stop getting
bigger and bigger and it's wonderful
that people can coin words and have them
actually show up in dictionaries two or
three years later he's right it's not
going to happen in France one of my
favorite literary critics Richard
Poirier is a very elegant and precise
stylist nonetheless I lie now and then
see a word in him and ha that's not the
dictionary so even critics can do it
because brilliantly have you ever
studied another language I have a
Hampstead French Latin yeah I've always
wondered I never asked asking about this
I've always wanted why writers throw the
little sometimes latin phrases but often
the French phrases in the books and
you're reading along if you're not a
French speaker you say I've just been
kind of gamed here I mean this guy's
telling me how smart he is why do people
do that sometimes to game the reader and
show how smart they are other times um
because though there ought to be an
English equivalent there isn't the one
that pops to mind is schadenfreude the
German word that means um pleasure in
the mishap coming to a friend
we don't have an English word that hits
exactly that and I understand why people
import it and pretty soon it will come
it'll probably just turn up as an
English word do you have a favorite or
favorite words that you like to use when
you're right when one of my colleagues
was reading through a book of mine he
noticed that I had a tendency toward
words like supreme and noble and
marvelous and splendid sothey
exclamatory a pat on the back is I guess
part of my stock and trade you have a
pet peeves about writing that you avoid
phrases you know dangling participles I
don't know you know what I'm getting it
I punctuated a lot I try to guide the
reader as much as I can um I try to be
as absolutely clear as possible and yet
I try not to be somebody who sacrifices
complexity at all so I was talking to a
group of students at the University of
Massachusetts this weekend and they knew
I was from Medford many of them were for
similar towns and they said hey you're
from Medford there are 50 words in here
that we don't know
I said well you can look at that as an
affront or you can look at it as a door
into new knowledge the great line of a
20th century American literary critic
Lee says that new words and new
metaphors increase the stock of
available reality you know there's
suddenly something you perceive as out
there that she didn't perceive before
well you can take it that way or you can
be kind of downcast no I don't know that
word that's a problem Gertrude
Himmelfarb heard a lot about the
Victorian period she's got this to say
about the language a good chunk of my
life reading and thinking about the
Victorians I find an enormous ly
stimulating
it's an enormous ly stimulating period
and these were very very thoughtful men
mind you while I was doing this I was
doing other things as well when I taught
for example I taught not only English
intellectual history where he also
taught about the Continental traditions
and the Germans and French Cohn Hegel
Marx and so on and it was very
interesting to see my Victorians in
contrast to the Continental thinkers the
continental think is very often much
more profound with more systematic more
ambitious as philosophers than the
English but lacking in a kind of humane
quality or that I always found in the
English yuria good stuff from in if it's
a matter of reading Dickens the most
humane comic and buoyant writer in
English maybe next to Shakespeare on the
one hand and reading one of the great
mid 19th century German philosophers
even you know my adored Schopenhauer
Nietzsche maybe the palm goes to
to Dickens but I like what Gertrude
Himmelfarb is saying about you know
making the Victorian period available to
people as a source of other values I
think she does this in her work of
values that they may want to maintain
sometimes in contrast to contemporary
values
you mentioned Schopenhauer and you also
write about him I do little I Chopin has
a very daring early Romantic philosopher
um he's extremely pessimistic very
tough-minded and is somebody who ends up
in his despair of human folly turning in
a direction that I've been exploring
more and more and that's Buddhist
thought why Buddhists um the Buddhist
philosophy of the will that the only way
to happiness is to curtail and subdue as
many desires as possible it's just
absolutely fascinating to me ultimately
I think it's a failure human beings
can't do it and suffer all kinds of
sorrows when they try to go too far in
terms of denying desire but there's
something very profound about it
nonetheless still you know Jacques Lacan
says talking about the Buddhist or
Buddhist renunciation of desire the
patient desires to have no desires and
when somebody desires to have no desires
you got a serious case of repression on
your hands are you becoming a Buddhist I
want to be influenced by the part of
Buddhism that emphasizes kindness
non-violence benevolence respect for
life um and yet because some of the
things that I'm inclined to say are
controversial I'll have to be aware that
though I affirm kindness and gentleness
nonetheless there's going to be some
inevitable friction and what I do and I
don't want to back off from that so the
poet I like the most
next Emerson is probably William Blake
he's a tough prophetic left-wing
revolutionary poet if you could combine
Blake's toughness and eagerness to
affect change with a sense of Buddhist
attachment and kindness you'd really be
going somewhere but that's tough to do
do you vote by the way absolutely did
you always vote absolutely what do you
find in your classrooms from your
students about being involved today in
politics a lot of skepticism virtually
blankets get
sysm some vote some don't but as
intelligent as they are and is engaged
in many aspects of life as they are the
great majority of my students think that
politics is a sham that one candidate is
the same as another and that voting is
neither here nor there now this is a
highly unscientific survey on my part
but it's something that is for many of
my even my brightest students
particularly the brightest students it
almost feels like a natural disposition
it's so potent Cornel West here's what
he had to say yet advantage of reading
is that there is a connection between
cultivating the art of living and
fighting courageously for the expansion
of democracy so the art of living is
learning how to die and what I mean by
that is is that if you're really going
to live life intensely then something in
you every day all the dies some bad
habits some prejudice some faulty
presuppositions so that you're
continually involved in a struggle to
better yourself become more mature more
compassionate more courageous democracy
he talked about it there you write about
democracy I'm gonna read a little bit in
a moment okay the people that you know
believe in democracy and around this
ecologist everybody believes in
democracy in a knee-jerk sorta way but
it's few people and I think Cornel West
is one of them it's one of the ones I
admire
who see democracy as a struggle you know
who understand that up until just a
couple of hundred years ago the belief
was pretty much pervasive that people
would know damn good and had to be ruled
from the top and and that the idea of
people ruling themselves is a great
experiment we're trying it out here and
it may fail you know if you look back in
the direction of other people who have
been democratic the Athenians the Air
Corps is the Vikings they have the good
qualities but frequently this to come to
an amazing hunger for violence so you
know it's an open-ended thing here's
what you write these professors whatever
they may say are fundamentally afraid of
living
in a democracy where people think for
themselves rather than letting experts
do their thinking for them this fear is
a scandal at the center of the current
day Academy though many professors claim
to be on the left the fact is that they
do not trust or sometimes even much like
everyday relatively unschooled people in
fact they tend to despise the people in
whose behalf they claim to be working
out extensive is that I may be hitting
higher rhetorical heights than I would
with the sentiments today but
nonetheless I think that the real
problem for people left and liberal like
myself is a strong mistrust of everyday
people they love bush they love NASCAR
they love football they beyond help
right so there's a certain amount of
contempt and frustration and I
understand those things particularly in
light of current politics and there's a
throwing up of the hands at the end and
there's a turning inward a desire to
talk only to ourselves and to our most
gifted students turning outward in the
direction of society even though we may
occasionally be laughed at our authority
may be undermined we may not get the
kind of response that we're looking for
I think that's a worthwhile thing and I
think that's part of the democratic
project you know democracy is as they
said in the Port Huron Statement getting
more and more people to take an active
role in making the decisions that matter
about the shaping of their lives
we wrote the Port Huron Statement the
various members of SDS who got together
I'm doing for Democratic Society right
years ago years ago right to to
fundamentally found the movement it's a
wonderful piece of populist John Dewey
type Democratic writing and I think that
we professors have often turned away
from that because of the frustrations
that are inevitable I mean when one
hears the worst kind of right-wing
rhetoric America is good strong just
true the rest of the world is inadequate
insofar as they don't follow our lead or
admire all of our habits and behaviors
this is real and it's really out there
and the idea of talking about Emerson or
Shakespeare into a context that's been
shaped by that kind of mean rhetoric is
very daunting and I understand why my
colleagues sometimes throw up their
hands but nonetheless I think it still
has to be done so how do you deal with
it on a day to day basis do you have to
talk yourself into allowing the other
side to be heard I have to talk myself
into sometimes writing for a general
audience knowing that I'm going to get
whatever agree is going to appear to me
to be uncomprehending kinds of reviews I
have to talk myself into sometimes you
know giving a lecture that's going to be
challenging to some of the people in the
room who may say ah this is just this is
just snobbishness going on here and you
know kind of take the hit from that and
go on but mostly I don't want I don't
want to affirm the negative I'm
incredibly grateful for the time that
I've gotten to spend in the university
I've had a wonderful life there and I'm
grateful to the entire system for what
it's what it's given me and and what
it's done and mostly it's a pleasure
right and when you can think as I can
think that I'm making some small
contribution to the sort of feeling that
West is talking about you know enhancing
people's capacity to grow and learn and
develop then that's a great privilege
and great gift and I'm grateful for it
Joker Conway used to be the president of
Smith College and she wrote about memoir
and here's what she had to say in 1998
I'm talking to a young woman who's just
finishing college and thinking about her
life ahead there are really very few
memoirs about a woman's education that
will help her think about it and also
very few that deal with how a young
adult woman sets about planning her life
and so I wanted to write a story that
would be a useful kind of roadmap for
somebody going through that process of
graduating from college and thinking
about the future what do you think of
that that kind of writing memoir well
I've written one I wrote one called
teacher and it was in homage to a
teacher that I really loved
Doug Meyers Michael Frank
years in the book who turned up in
Medford High School my working-class
high school and affected a sort of
miracle for us so I think that kind of
thing that potentially inspiring memoir
is a great honor and I'm pleased to have
contributed a little fragment to it
I do hope somewhat in distinction to
what Conway says that um there will be
women her able to be inspired by men's
memoirs and men inspired by women so
that we can learn from each other it
need not be only women reading I'm not
cents so I say that's what she's
suggesting but we can the gender the
genders can learn from each other in
this regard go back to the title of your
book who I read if again someone is
watching and they've not been a big
reader what would you tell them about
starting I would tell should they start
I think that the best way to start is
with two thoughts in mind dr. Johnson
says about boys reading he says just let
them read anything they want they'll get
good books later on so I would encourage
people to read what it is they like and
what they drawn to with the idea that
someday they're going to graduate to
Shakespeare or Emerson or Emily
Dickinson and I encourage them to be
compiling a list of writers whose names
or details about them have always
intrigued and though what they may be
reading be reading now isn't the strong
stuff they're not in the Olympics of
reading and writing nonetheless they're
looking to go in that direction because
it can give your life more than the easy
stuff can but you got to start somewhere
if you had your time would you prefer a
fiction over nonfiction or which one
would you prefer I am myself as a
professor of English always go for the
fiction and poetry because it's more
intimate and personal and immediate and
it helps people to do one of the things
that I think is most important for their
development helps them to learn how to
talk to themselves those are very deep
and inward voices that you get in a good
novel from the narrator and in a good
poem and once you can start to reproduce
those not those voices in your own
spirit you've taken a really good step
forward in the kind of growth
West is talking about Christopher
Hitchens here's 30 seconds on radical
writing I think of the radical writers
the the outstanding cases this what I
mentioned go for dad already I think is
one of the best writers of this or any
other time and who is the person I most
I guess tried to model myself on in that
he's so much of a polymath and he has
such a range and it tries to synthesize
literature and politics very brilliantly
so I openly confess to to a sort of firm
we won't say penis envy for goal that I
wouldn't you know what I mean it's kind
of writing work it does Hitchens is a
terrific writer of envy dollars as well
I often find them to be for all their
riches writers her writing so much into
the present in the immediate moment or
so topical that the thought of reading
them twice is a little bit daunting
here's an older book spoken about by
Milton Friedman on the other side okay
it's a book well worth reading by
anybody because there's a very subtle
analysis of why how it is that
well-meaning people who intent only to
improve the lot of their fellows tend to
favor courses of action which have
exactly the opposite effect I think in
my for my point of view the most
interesting chapter in that book is one
labeled why the worst rise to the top
he's talking about Road to Serfdom Hayek
a Bible for people on the conservative
political side hmm I'm glad to know
about it until this moment I've heard
nothing about it but I will write it
down and give it a look so you've never
read Road deserved never know heard of
it until this moment
mark Edmondson we're out of time thank
you for joining us here's what the book
looks like why Reid University of
Virginia professor mark Edmondson thank
you very much for joining us thank you